so starting out this devoid logic video
we have the very first sequence of the
movie
the first 12 minutes basically has
nothing to do with the rest of the story
so the fact that the sequence is in the
movie to begin with is devoid of logic
this is just a flashback and all we
learn is that cheating
is bad you cheated diana
that is the only truth and truth is all
there is
wow what a massive revelation also one
other stupid moment in this sequence is
that we start out with
nine people but there are only five
horses on the shore waiting for them
as if they knew there would only be five
people remaining after the obstacle
course
also in the first movie they made it
really clear that diana was not allowed
to do
any training she is a child the only
child on the island
there will be no training so how does
this little girl with practically little
to no training somehow almost beat all
of these seasoned warriors
her mother was very protective over her
in the first movie
but for some reason she's fine with her
daughter competing in the amazonian
olympics
wouldn't it also be a red flag that her
daughter is somehow better than all
these warriors
and maybe she's been training in secret
like there's just no consistency between
the two movies
it feels like this whole sequence is
just a reshoot the filmmakers probably
panicked because of how long the movie
was and how little action it had
so they probably just threw the scene
into the movie because before this there
were only like 4 action scenes total
so let's get into the crappy wishing
stone mcguffin that drives most of the
conflict
in the movie in general there are a lot
of plot holes with this power
firstly as an example if you wish for a
nuke you get a nuke
but diana wishes for steve to come back
and for some reason steve took the
consciousness of another person
that doesn't make a lot of sense
considering the fact that wishes can
materialize things
also i know this is a monkey's paw but
the downside for this wish was that
diana was slowly losing her powers
so i guess she gets two downsides for
her wish then
also regarding the fact that steve comes
back in another person
is diana just okay with the moral
ramifications of taking over an innocent
person's life
like the guy turned out to be a cool
dude by the end of the movie and diana
just hijacks his life
she's supposed to be the good guy but
when it comes to building her long lost
love
it's okay i guess on the topic of steve
let's take a look at one of the scenes
him and diana have together that is
completely devoid of logic
and that scene is the fighter jet scene
so diane and steve need a jet to fly to
cairo and stop max lord
but the means in which they get the jet
is really stupid
they end up going to a smithsonian and
in the back lot they just have a fully
fueled and ready to take off fighter jet
which is not a thing at all those planes
are on display and they normally don't
function
let alone one of them having enough fuel
to get to cairo
so after that stupid logic steve
miraculously knows how to fly the jet
with the justification that
he's a pilot that's so easy really it's
it's wind and air and knowing how to
how to ride it how to catch it and
apparently there is no learning curve
from a world war one propeller plane to
a fighter jet
that and in this clip it is clear he
doesn't know what he's doing
no after they are taking off they
realize that
oh no they have a radar and they can
shoot us down
well [ __ ] diana and what happens diana
can now turn things invisible
which is oddly convenient there is no
build up or anything she just now
remembers how to do it conveniently
my father hit the mascara from the world
and i've been trying to learn how we did
it
did what made something invisible even
if that's a thing in the comics
the execution of it within the movie
doesn't make sense
so after that domino effect of stupid
events we hit our next domino
and that is it's suddenly the 4th of
july
4th of course the 4th of july
there's no buildup to this at all and
they just randomly threw this in for
spectacle
also why is steve surprised by fireworks
it's not like they were invented a long
time ago so yeah this whole scene is
completely devoid of logic
and just doesn't make a lot of sense so
looking back at the villain and the wish
aspect of the movie there are still a
lot of things that don't make sense
for the secondary villain named barbara
she initially wishes to have wonder
woman's powers
and then she is offered another wish and
with that wish she wants to be an apex
predator
an apex predator like nothing there's
ever been before
that alone is pretty stupid because why
would you want to turn into a cheetah
when you already have super strength and
everything else that wonder woman has
but maybe she's a furry behind the
scenes you never know
then by the end of the movie wonder
woman holds her under the water while
she gets electrocuted
but if barbara has the same powers as
wonder woman then shouldn't she be fine
or does the second wish remove their
first wishes benefits
i don't know it doesn't make sense and
it isn't explained properly
also during the beginning of the fight
wonder woman is wearing some sick golden
armor that is set up to be very durable
they even show this in a flashback where
an amazonian holds off an onslaught of
spartans
and the armor doesn't get damaged but
after a few strikes from barbara
the armor falls apart like a poorly
constructed lego set
at the end of the movie max lord makes
the president wish for something which
in return he takes presidentship
and then he broadcasts himself to the
entire world and asks everyone to make
wishes
but nobody makes a wish for world peace
or to even wish for this guy to stop
talking out of all these people making
wishes there would at least be one
person to wish for something to save the
day
or to essentially end the world but in
general this doesn't make sense
then after all the nonsense and wonder
woman losing to some wind
i'm not exaggerating there she literally
loses to wind
and she can't fight through it with her
super strength which is honestly just
really funny and stupid
but going back to my point is that max
lord renounces his wish
and loses all of his powers and benefits
but for some reason the presidential
helicopter decided to give this maniac
a ride back to washington dc like this
guy was about to end the world why would
anyone help him
i'm just assuming that the filmmakers
wouldn't think that the audience would
question this
also i want to point out that max lord
has a kid that just sat in his office
for an entire day
right now i need you to stay here with
emerson okay i'll be back if you stay
here
and in this shot he is just now coming
out of the office when it's night time
like what the hell did this kid do for
the whole movie did he just sit there
staring at a wall
and then after everything goes to [ __ ]
he just runs away and ends up on a
freeway
why would this kid suddenly just wander
onto a freeway where it's dangerous
kids shouldn't be that stupid then when
maxlord returns to washington dc
he calls out for his son and he suddenly
just emerges from the shrubs
like what he was just on a freeway and
now he's just miraculously here
man this movie just doesn't make any
sense so going into another aspect of
the movie that is devoid of logic
i wanted to take a look at the physics i
know this is a superhero movie and
physics shouldn't really matter that
much
but when they look this bad i have to
say something
whenever diana is running it just looks
like she is ice skating
when you run normally your head is
bobbing up and down
but for diana she just keeps her head at
the same level constantly
and it looks fake and this is just the
physics regarding the running
a lot of the time when she's using her
lasso it doesn't look very good
the first thing that comes to mind is
the mall scene like in this one shot as
an example
it looks like she just levitates up
instead of there being a swinging motion
another scene where the physics are
broken is when diana saves the kids on
the street from the convoy
she's basically rocketing towards them
at about a hundred miles an hour
and they play the shot in slow motion to
make the physics look more believable
in reality she would have broken every
bone in their tiny little bodies
and then after this she ends up just
losing her grip anyways and she just
falls on them so i don't know how
they're still alive
besides the physics in the scene it
doesn't make sense for these kids to be
playing on the street
because do they not see or hear a
massive convoy shooting guns heading
towards them
i guess the movie probably just needed
to make it up a way to stop wonder woman
from catching max lord in this scene
going back to the subject of physics how
the hell
is diana able to fly apparently
if she poses like superman that gives
her the ability to fly i know she is
shooting herself forward with her lasso
but she should immediately start falling
is she not just falling with style
thank you all thank you that wasn't
flying that was
falling with style at this point the
filmmakers basically just made her
superman with the added benefit of
making objects invisible
i don't know overall this movie
essentially is just built on plot
contrivances
mcguffins plot holes and overall bad
writing
i can go on longer about all the small
details that are devoid of logic
but the points i talked about in this
video cover most of what was wrong with
the movie
let me know in the comments what you
guys thought about wonder woman 1984
and i hope you enjoyed the video